these lights may look like a city from
the sky
but they're fishing vessels just outside
argentina's exclusive economic zone
there are hundreds of them
argentina's coast guards say their main
task is to control their movements
so they do not cross into argentine
territory
argentina you have vessels with
argentine flags
and vessels with foreign flags all of
these are ships that have been detected
by our system
when there is irregular activity they
tend to shut down their radars
but we can still track them with
satellites
illegal fishing can generate millions of
dollars in losses
and cause irreparable damage to
ecosystems
that's why it's one of the biggest
challenges nations face today
from this room argentine authorities can
monitor what's happening in its economic
exclusive
zones but what authorities here are
saying is that what's important
is to regulate what's happening in
international waters and
where most of these vessels that you can
see here are located
the ships come mostly from china but
also spain portugal and japan
this year the united states launched
operation southern cross
to combat illegal and unregulated
fishing in the southern atlantic
they participated in joint operations
with brazil uruguay
and guyana we'll not only focus on
training and qualification issues
related to the cutter and crew itself
but we'll also focus on partnering with
south atlantic
countries that have a like-minded
approach to curbing illegal unreported
and unregulated fishing habits
greenpeace argentina has been
highlighting the damage caused by
unregulated fishing in the area
in 2018 the ship experianza
reached what is known as the blue hole
where argentina's exclusive economic
zone is located
and captured images from the seabed
biologists say
it has been devastated by overfishing
and inadequate policing of international
waters
there's no regulation there's no law in
international waters
we need a new treaty that's being
debated at the u.n it will allow
countries to create sanctuaries
international waters are 45 percent of
the water worldwide
only one percent is protected the treaty
will be debated at the u.n in august
those who supported hope it will give
nations more tools
to protect their territories and the
thousands of species
currently under threat teresa al jazeera
buenos aires